the trial is closed you have a lot of
good sources you've learned to be a
reporter like your brother through all
of this what have you what if anything
have you learned about what happened in
the proceedings today well you know we
found out only yesterday that the trial
was going to be closed we've been
petitioning to have it be an open trial
yet so we could get some transparency
it's actually illegal for any
information to come out from the trial
so clearly we're not getting anything
from there but what we do know is the
trial first day lasted about two hours
my mom and my sister-in-law were both
went down to the court but were not able
to go into the courtroom Jason was
accompanied by his attorney there was a
english translator there from the
government and the expectation is on
that first day they would read the
evidence against him to read the charges
against him and there would be some
conversation that went on around that
alley there tube we would rather there
were two piece of evidence that the
Iranian government feels are in some way
incriminating of your brother one of
which is a visa application and the
other of which is a form letter that he
sent to the Obama administration well
it's a little vague exactly what those
what why those documents would be
considered incriminating from the point
of view of the Iranian officials and
what exactly that second document was
can you should light on those two things
yeah sure I mean as far as part of our
work we take a look at whatever we could
that we thought could be used against
Jason in those two particular cases
there was a process during the
transition before President Obama took
office to let people go online and send
in informations and basically apply for
a job almost what do you think about the
new president and how how can you help
Jason actually sent a letter he said
I've lived in Iran
I love Iran I grew up in the united
states i love the United States I want
our countries to be more harmonious how
can I help you guys out is there
anything I can do in the upcoming
administration that's basically the
extent of that letter it was filled out
on a web form online and he did receive
a response which said this is an
automated response we have received your
submission dude just to be clear you say
there was an application for a job it
wasn't officially an application for a
job he was basically saying look if
you're interested in somebody who
understands Iran understands the Iranian
culture and can help you you know speak
more clearly with the Iranian government
I'd like to help you write your brother
has been there for a number of years was
he worried before this incident was he
worried that he might have something
like this happened to him you know I
don't think that anybody could have
thought that something like this was
going to happen this is just so far
outside the bounds of what had happened
before to any prior Western journalist
Jason was meticulous and how he followed
the rules all journalists in Iran are
credentialed he knew where he could go
you know there's a process there what's
your theory then about why he was single
debt you know I think it's hard to say
Jason you know he is one of the only
Americans over there that was reporting
he has a lot of friends and a lot of
people think that it might have had
something to do with internal politics
trying to get some pressure on the
President or something in that country
or else something else we really don't
know when you when you folks in the
family when you deal with the
administration and talk to them is I'm
sure you have repeatedly over the course
of the time that he's been in captivity
who do you deal with and and one of the
nature of those of the interchanges
you've had with the government about
this the US countries yeah yeah we speak
with a variety of people in the US
government primarily over in the State
Department their folks over there and
I've spoken people with different levels
we have a contact over there who we
talked with she's very good at getting
information from us as well as helping
us
out to other governments when we need to
is for example reaching out to the
protecting power the Swiss in in Iran to
try and maybe that send letters to
officials over there things like that
I've also spoken to folks up on the hill
as well Senators Congressmen there at
aids was really happy last week to see
the unanimous resolution in the Senate
calling for the US government to do
everything possible to bring Jason and
the other Americans own are there things
you've asked the administration to do
that they have rebuffed you on and
they've told you they would not do no
not really we haven't made any specific
requests like that we've we've asked
them about things we've heard maybe we
hear a rumor is that something that is
is true those kinds of things and when
we wanted to ask allayed things we've
been able to escalate them can you tell
me how you feel about Iran now you know
I think I feel the same way as I did
before the people they really love
Americans are really nice and the
government does what it wants to do you
know they say that they've got a lot of
laws and they choose one they want to
follow them and when they don't